et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
pas pendji bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale bonjour Stéphane Vernet
bonjour Stéphane de westfrance qui est
avec nous on va évidemment parler de
l'éducation nationale et notamment de la
question de l'éducation dans les
territoires ruraux puisque c'est un
sujet que vous avez abordé mais d'abord
je le disais vous êtes aussi ministre de
la Jeunesse la contestation contre la
réforme de la retraite est toujours
vivait elle s'étend à la jeunesse est-ce
que vous êtes inquiète cette
mobilisation de la jeunesse est-ce
qu'elle peut pousser le gouvernement
reculer il y a des jeunes dans les
mobilisations et dans les manifestations
c'est incontestable mais ça n'est pas
une mobilisation de la jeunesse la
mobilisation de la jeunesse elle ne se
fait pas d'ailleurs d'un point de vue
historique sur les questions proprement
liées au retraites si vous regardez
l'historique les réformes de retraite
depuis 1993 elle se fait sur d'autres
questions et donc la question c'est de
savoir si des éléments extérieurs à la
réforme des retraites vont au mouvement
ça n'est pas mon sentiment à l'heure
actuelle vous pensez pas qui peut avoir
une coagulation des colères nous
observons les choses à mon sens on n'est
pas encore dans un mouvement qui
relèverait d'une mobilisation de la
jeunesse on va à chaque journée
manifestation on parle de de lycée ou de
fac bloqué est-ce que est-ce que ce sont
vraiment des établissements bloqués et
combien dans quelle proportions il y en
a très peu quelques dizaines à chaque
fois au nombre décroissant d'ailleurs ce
sont des vrais blocages ou c'est
purement symbolique ce sont des blocages
d'entrée d'établissement d'ailleurs qui
pose des problèmes de sécurité c'est
pour cela que nous sommes opposés au
blocage de lycée mais leur nombre est en
fait tout à fait réduit il est situé
dans des grandes villes dans des lycées
que nous connaissons bien qui ont des
traditions militantes par ailleurs tout
à fait respectable mais nous sommes
évidemment attachés d'une part à la
continuité pédagogique j'observe que le
bac des épreuves de spécialité du bac se
sont très bien déroulées et le salut au
passage la responsabilité de celles et
ceux qui ont appelé à ce que ces
épreuves se déroulent au mieux
aucun impact sur les épreuves de
spécialité je peux vous dire d'ailleurs
qu'il n'y a pas d'impact non plus sur la
correction qui se poursuit tout à fait
normalement et donc les choses se sont
bien passées nous sommes tout à fait
rassurés de ce point de vue là et pardon
parmi les revendiquent les
revendications on entend des choses qui
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la réforme
des retraites notamment il y a des
demandes sur la la suppression du
nouveau bac
la suppression du nouveau bac on a pu
l'entendre ou en tout cas les épreuves
de spécialité je rappelle que ces
épreuves de spécialité qui ont eu lieu
au mois de mars donc pour la première
fois finalement depuis l'instauration de
la réforme après 2019 ce que ça aurait
dû avoir lieu la première fois en 2020
c'est ça
dire il faut supprimer le nouveau bac on
pourrait aussi bien supprimer le bac
pourquoi pas je pense que ça ferait
plaisir sans doute
bien entendu dans le monde entier le bac
ou l'équivalent du baccalauréat conjugue
pour l'essentiel du contrôle continu
avec quelques épreuves finales c'est le
cas du bac actuel et donc les épreuves
de spécialité qui ont eu lieu au mois de
mars vont être prises en compte dans
parcoursup pour la première fois ce qui
est très important de manière à ce que
les universités par exemple est une
sorte de norme nationale avec des sujets
identiques
à l'ensemble des lycéens ça c'est un
élément je dirais de justice d'égalité
pour l'entrée dans le supérieur et puis
c'est également un élément qui favorise
au fond
l'investissement des lycéens sur leur
spécialité puisqu'elles comptent plus
que les années précédentes dans les
affectations dans les universités donc
pas de changement à venir sur la réforme
des on peut on va pouvoir retoucher bien
entendu on va observer ce qui s'est
passé on va pouvoir notamment sur les
sujets éventuellement faire des petites
retouches lorsque le moment sera venu de
faire le bilan du baccalauréat on est on
est conscient aussi de ce qu'il y a à
faire à propos de parcoursup il y a des
améliorations à apporter encore à
parcoursup en particulier du point de
vue de l'orientation des élèves nous ne
sommes pas complètement satisfaits de
l'orientation des lycéens dans le cadre
de la procédure parcoursup
au choix des différentes
options sur parcoursup si on aide
familiale pour cela c'est très bien si
ça n'est pas le cas c'est plus compliqué
donc on doit travailler sur
l'orientation sur l'aide que le lycée
que les professeurs en particulier
doivent apporter il y a des élèves
et des familles exactement et donc on
doit progresser de ce point de vue là
c'est incontestable d'année en année
parcoursup s'améliore mais nous du côté
d'éducation nationale nous avons à faire
notre part du travail on fera le bilan
de tout cela mais je peux vous dire
jusqu'à présent que les épreuves se sont
bien passées d'une manière générale à la
satisfaite il y a plus de conseillers
d'orientation dans les lycées ici
toujours il y a des conseillers
pas suffisamment et puis on a confié
également aux professeur principaux qui
sont deux en termes
d'accompagner alors ils le font parfois
très très bien parfois faute de temps ça
se fait moins bien la réforme elle-même
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'elle va
changer notamment pour les enseignants
pour les professeurs ce qui a beaucoup
de professeurs qui vont être obligés de
partir à plus de 64 ans alors fais de la
réforme des retraites
à 64 ans donc la question n'est pas
absolument révolutionnaire pour les
professeurs de même que les jeunes
professeurs contenus de l'enseignants
parce qu'ils n'ont ils n'ont pas ils
n'ont pas toutes leurs activités
d'accord exactement et donc les jeunes
professeurs qui rentrent dans le métier
avec un bac + 5 parfois un peu plus on
fait leur calcul et même sans la réforme
des retraites il serait parti de toute
façon à plus de 62 ans à 64 ou 65 ans
donc la réforme des retraites ne change
de la retraite ne change pas
radicalement les choses pour un très
grand nombre d'enseignants et par
ailleurs nous proposons la retraite
progressive deux ans avant de faire
valeur ses droits à la retraite pour les
enseignants le départ à date
anniversaire pour les professeurs des
écoles et puis des augmentations aussi
de rémunération en fin de carrière qui
vont permettre aussi que la pension qui
est calculée sur les six derniers mois
soit une pension revalorisée tout ça ce
sont des éléments qui mi bout à bout
font que la réforme des retraites n'a
qu'un impact relatif est-ce qu'elle est
avantageuse pour les professeurs cette
réforme des retraites est-ce qu'il y a
des améliorations quand une manière
générale la réforme des retraites elle
réclame un effort personne n'est content
de travailler plus longtemps quelques
mois de plus voire deux ans de plus à
partir de 2030 ça concerne aussi un
certain nombre de professeurs il faut le
reconnaître c'est un effort que l'on
réclame au pays pour nos enfants et pour
nos petits-enfants de travailler plus
avec cette réforme tout à fait notamment
des professeurs qui sont en fin de
carrière et qui voient en quelque sorte
la ligne d'arrivée reculée de quelques
mois puisque la réforme va être mise en
place de trois mois en trois mois mais
pour une grande masse de professeurs ça
ne change pas grand chose en réalité
parce que de toute façon il serait parti
au delà de 62 ans est-ce que pour vous
c'est ce qui explique le faible plutôt
de grévistes dans le dans le corps
enseignant les journées de mobilisation
c'est c'est assez faible ça a plutôt
tendance à baisser ou pas oui je dirais
que les enseignants ont participé de
façon relativement importante au moins
au début à la mobilisation et puis
ensuite les chiffres ont des crus la
réforme en elle-même à certes bien
entendu et on peut le comprendre
susciter des oppositions néanmoins les
enseignants n'ont pas été je dirais les
faire de lance de la mobilisation comme
on a pu le voir dans le passé parce que
les conditions que vous leur proposez
sont bonnes ou simplement parce qu'il y
a un problème d'argent aussi faire grève
ça coûte ça coûte à la longueur
je pense que le calcul les enseignants
ont fait leurs calculs et ils se rendent
compte que la réforme telle qu'elle est
proposée n'a qu'un impact bien entendu
en particulier pour les enseignants qui
sont en fin de carrière mais dans des
proportions qui restent relativement
rapide scolaire c'est un peu le
professeur il est là il fait une année
scolaire est-ce que s'il a date de la
retraite tombe avant la fin de l'année
scolaire ils pourront partir c'est le
cas déjà dans le secondaire les
professeurs
ce sera aussi le cas pour les
professeurs des écoles qui pourront
partir à la date de leur anniversaire
même si on sait que beaucoup d'entre eux
choisiront
voilà et de conserver leur classe sur le
service national universel est-ce qu'il
est victime de ce climat social est-ce
que ça généralisation est abandonnée
plusieurs options sont sur la table pour
l'instant et elles sont explorées et ce
sera aux présidents de la République de
tranchée de faire les annonces à ce
sujet il y a une partie qui doit être
fait pendant le temps et une hors du
temps scolaire quel est l'option qui a
votre préférence il y a plusieurs
options moi je
nous regardons les possibilités il y a
plus que deux options en réalité en tout
cas il y a la question du temps scolaire
bien entendu mais pour l'instant pour
l'instant rien n'est définitivement
arrêté ni du point de vue de la date ni
du point de vue du contenu des alentours
quand est-ce qu'on sera fixé parce que
là il y a un grand flou on ça devait
être annoncé on doit avoir des annonces
en début d'année puis après on nous a
dit février mars c'est plus le temps
passé et plus la contestation montait
plus le plus le calendrier devenait flou
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui je vous avais un
cadre votre votre impatience mais ça va
venir on va parler de l'éducation dans
les territoires ruraux puisque vous avez
fait un déplacement à ce sujet avec la
première mise dans la Nièvre est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des inégalités
territoriales en matière d'éducation
alors le principe du service public
d'éducation c'est de couvrir l'ensemble
du territoire y compris d'ailleurs des
territoires très isolé j'ai souvenir
d'une petite école que j'ai visité au
milieu de l'île de la Réunion qu'on
atteint après plusieurs heures de marche
c'est une école très isolée qui
symbolise le service public d'éducation
alors ça c'est le principe mais est-ce
que dans la réalité dans la réalité il y
a effectivement alors ce qui est ce qui
est vrai c'est que dans les territoires
ruraux la question de l'éloignement se
pose une façon beaucoup plus évidente
que dans des territoires urbains lorsque
les écoles sont relativement proches les
unes des autres et dans un contexte qui
est le nôtre qui est celui d'une baisse
des effectifs scolaires une baisse
extrêmement accentuée nous perdons
bonhomme allant 80 à 100 000 élèves par
an 500 000 élèves sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat ces questions là se posent
avec une acuité particulière d'où le
déplacement que j'ai fait avec la
première ministre dans la Nièvre pour
mettre en valeur notre attention
particulière sur des territoires qui en
effet ont des caractéristiques
démographiques et d'éloignement qui
méritent des mesures spécifiques est-ce
qu'il y a pas aussi la question de la
formation est-ce que vous avez les mêmes
options les mêmes possibilités quand
vous êtes dans un collège ou un lycée
dans un territoire oral ou dans un
territoire urbain est-ce que là vous
allez mettre des moyens pour diversifier
la formation alors il en effet la
question de la taille des collèges les
collèges dans les territoires ruraux
peuvent être de petites tailles et donc
certaines options par exemple des
options de langue ne sont pas
disponibles dans ces collèges nous
souhaitons en effet implantés dans ces
collèges ruraux des filières attractives
par exemple des sections internationales
des sections sportives ou des sections
artistiques de manière à donner un peu
de lustre au collège en question et à
attirer des élèves ou à garder des
élèves ou à attirer des familles puisque
bien entendu le collège est un élément
important dans les dans le choix des des
ça nous pouvons le faire c'est à la main
de l'éducation nationale que d'installer
des filières attractives mais nous avons
aussi besoin du côté des écoles qui sont
prioritairement concernés nous avons
aussi besoin je crois d'une vision
pluriannuelle des choses vous savez le
maire d'une autre puisque les enfants
qui naissent aujourd'hui sont les
enfants qui auront à l'école dans trois
ans donc trois ans c'est le bon laps de
temps pour avoir une un peu de
profondeur de champ si je puis dire et
concrètement ça veut dire quoi par
exemple ça veut dire qu'il y aura pas de
fermeture de classe en milieu rurale
dans les trois prochaines années les
choses sont figées pour pour servir
maintenant ça veut dire que nous allons
nous engager avec les maires sur un une
je dirais pas non pas sur le fait de
geler la situation puisque les effectifs
scolaires peuvent baisser ou au
contraire augmenter mais en tout cas
nous avons besoin de nous engager sur
trois ans avec le maire vous savez si
vous prenez l'exemple d'un maire qui
reçoit une subvention de la part de la
préfecture pour rénover son école et qui
dans la foulée se voit fermer une classe
je comprends que le maire en question
soit désemparé face à une ça veut dire
que à partir d'aujourd'hui vous dites ce
matin aux élus locaux on va se mettre
autour de la table on va discuter et
pendant trois ans rien ne bouge non non
ce que nous disons c'est à partir de
l'automne nous allons nous réunir avec
les préfectures avec les directions
académiques donc l'éducation nationale
avec les maires pour regarder sur trois
ans ce qui va se passer dans leur
commune l'implantation d'un lotissement
l'installation de tel ou tel activité
économique prévue pour dans tel ou tel
période ça ça compte évidemment dans les
choix que nous allons faire de manière à
ce que le maire puisse avoir une vision
sur trois ans de la polymère
exactement et ça à partir de la rentrée
2024 donc de 2024 et cela va se mettre
en place à partir de cet autom ces
discussions et ses échanges de manière à
ce que tout le monde puisse se concerter
et qu'on ait une vision à peu près
correcte votre présence votre
prédécesseur Jean-Michel Blanquer avait
prévu qu'il y aurait pas de fermeture de
classe en milieu rurale si les maires ou
les élus locaux s'y opposaient est-ce
que ça ça existe vraiment ça vraiment
être fatigué de la République avait et
nous évidemment nous tenons à ce
principe
réellement qu'il n'y a pas de fermeture
d'école et pas fait de fermeture de
classe c'est différent
vous voulez plus de concertation est-ce
que ça veut dire que ce sont les mers
qui auront le dernier mot sur les
fermetures de classe non c'est
l'éducation nationale mais nous avons
besoin d'échanges et de concertation
avec les mers les mers sont nos
partenaires en la matière nous devons
donc les écouter et les regarder la
situation de leur commune avec
suffisamment de profondeur de champ pour
que
ça ne se faisait pas
c'est vous qui décidez c'est à dire
qu'un maire ne pourra pas s'opposer à
une fermeture de classe décidée par
l'éducs ça ne peut pas ne peut pas
s'opposer à une fermeture de classe mais
heureusement bien entendu c'est le cas
aujourd'hui beaucoup de maires
comprennent les décisions de fermeture
de classe quand il n'y a plus que 5
élèves oui il faut fermer les classes
mais ce qu'ils demandent de façon très
insistante et je les comprends c'est
d'avoir qu'on les préviennent
suffisamment de temps à l'avance et
qu'il puisse également nous informer de
leur projet de manière à ce que nous
nous puissions prendre les décisions en
conséquences vous allez travailler à
quelle échelle vous allez travailler à
l'échelle des communes la l'échelle des
intercommunalités est-ce que vous
encouragez les mères à travailler entre
eux justement pour proposer des
solutions intercommunales oui nous
encourageons les RPI les regroupements
pédagogiques intercommunaux c'est une
manière à l'échelle de plusieurs
communes de regrouper des écoles dans
les effectifs baisse et par exemple de
d'organiser par niveau selon chaque
école la distribution des élèves donc
cela se fait et nous proposons
d'ailleurs un bonus supplémentaire pour
les regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux un bonus en termes de
moyens humains de manière à encourager
ce qui se fait d'ailleurs j'ai eu
l'occasion dans visiter les RPI qui
fonctionnent très bien par exemple en
savoir de manière à ce que c'est RPI
puisse au fond répondre à une à des
logiques démographiques qui sont
malheureusement actuellement celles
d'une baisse des effectifs et puis les
RPI ont par ailleurs des intérêts
pédagogiques intéressants à condition
bien entendu que les transports
scolaires ne soient pas trop importants
mais c'est généralement le cas vous avez
annoncé certaines mesures vendredi avec
la première nuit est-ce que vous en
préparez d'autres mesures en faveur de
l'éducation dans la ruralité oui donc
la plus réanualité on vient d'en parler
la question également des territoires
éducatifs ruraux que nous souhaitons
développer pour l'instant il y en a une
soixantaine nous souhaitons généraliser
les territoires éducatifs ruraux alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce que ces
territoires et bien ce sont des des
mises en réseau de collèges parfois de
lycée et d'école de manière à faire
travailler ensemble c'est ce qu'on a vu
dans la Nièvre par exemple avec la
première ministre de manière à faire
travailler ensemble école et collège à
faire travailler ensemble le scolaire le
périscolaire et l'extrascolaire c'est un
peu l'équivalent dans le rural des cités
éducatives dans les mondes urbains et on
s'aperçoit que les résultats sont tout à
fait prometteurs on a besoin de faire de
mettre en réseau on a besoin de faire
circuler on a besoin également d'assurer
de meilleurs liaison entre le primaire
et le secondaire vous savez l'importance
que j'attache à la classe de 6e pour que
ça marche évidemment il faut qu'il y ait
des professeurs des enseignants comment
vous allez faire pour attirer ces
professeurs dans les territoires ruraux
et bien il faut d'abord mieux les payer
c'est pour ça que on va les revaloriser
à partir de la rentrée avec ce qu'on
appelle la revalorisation socle c'est
quoi la revalorisation socle et bien
c'est une revalorisation pour tous les
professeurs quelle que soit d'ailleurs
la date d'entrée dans le métier les néo
titulaires comme ceux qui sont en fin de
carrière ça c'est prévu à partir de
septembre une revalorisation de combien
oncle alors on va l'annoncer bientôt ce
sera une revalorisation très
substantielle conformément aux
engagements du Président très
substantiel vous vous le verrez mais ce
sera tout à fait
significatifs
ce sera un montant ou ce sera un
pourcentage par rapport à l'ancienneté
par rapport à leur site actuel ce sera
un pourcentage par rapport au salaire un
pourcentage significatif qui correspond
évidemment à un montant qui sera un
montant important nous allons le
préciser dans quelques jours
conformément aux engagements du
Président
d'accord ce sera aussi valable pour les
personnels de direction pour les
personnels administrations augmenter le
temps de travail des enseignants sans
condition ça c'est la revalorisation
socle valorisation également un autre
volet qui sera conditionné à de
nouvelles missions qu'on appelle le
pacte qui représentera à peu près une
augmentation de 10% supplémentaires par
rapport au salaire moyen donc quelque
chose comme
3750 euros pour les enseignants qui
choisiront ces nouvelles missions ce
sera facultatif en plus de la
revalorisation soit en plus de la
revalorisation socle
à de nouvelles missions comme par
exemple les remplacements de courte
durée vous savez qu'on perd 15 millions
d'heures annuelles pour des
remplacements qui ne sont pas assurés
avec des emplois du temps à trous ce qui
a un problème pour les élèves et pour
les familles alors Emmanuel Macron qu'on
puisse remplacer les professeurs du jour
au lendemain j'imagine que c'est votre
réponse c'est que les enseignants
assurent les missions mais par exemple
vous avez un élève dont le professeur de
mathématiques est absent qu'est-ce que
vous faites vous demandez à son prof
d'histoire-géo à son prof de français
devenir le remplacer voilà pour les
professeurs qui ce qui auront choisi le
pacte et bien si le professeur de
mathématiques est absent le professeur
d'histoire-géo pourra assurer leur par
exemple d'absence dans l'emploi dans
l'emploi du temps pas pour faire des
mathématiques mais pour faire de
l'histoire-géographie et donc les élèves
auront voilà et les élèves ont plus
d'histoire-géographie une semaine ils
auront plus de mathématiques une autre
semaine par un jeu de ta caisse si vous
voulez par lesquels on vise à une
annualisation en quelque sorte des
heures de cours plutôt que d'avoir
exactement le même nombre où le nombre
d'heures requises par semaine et donc
l'objectif c'est de réduire le nombre
d'or non assurées voilà une mission
importante que nous proposons aux
professeur du secondaire pour les
professeurs du primaire pour le
professeur des écoles nous allons leur
proposer notamment cette heure de
soutien en mathématiques ou en français
qui est assuré qui sera assuré à partir
de la rentrée pour les élèves de 6e
sera à l'heure effectuée elle sera
valorisée comment elle sera valorisée
sous une forme
indemnitaire donc sous la forme d'un on
appelle ça dans notre jargon des briques
avec trois briques possibles des briques
d'environ 1250 euros donc chaque
enseignant pourra choisir une deux ou
trois briques donc c'est un système
assez souple trois briques ça fait un
ensemble le pacte à
3750 euros et donc
l'enseignant s'engagera à une deux ou
plusieurs missions qui correspondent à
ce pacte par exemple des remplacements
de courte durée il faut être assez loin
dans sa carrière quand même pour toucher
ce salaire donc c'est pas un salaire
c'est
là c'est le pacte c'est la prime qui
sera composé en plus la revalorisation
plus la troisième brique à ce moment-là
vous êtes à 3750
la revalorisation socle ça c'est
l'augmentation pour tout le monde et en
plus une prime annuelle de 3750 €
pardon c'est ça que j'avais pas très
bien compris
vous dites évidemment que il faut
encourager le métier de prof il faut
rendre un tractif est-ce que il y aura
encore des suppressions de poste dans
l'éducation nationale chez les
professeurs alors il y a il va y avoir
des suppressions de poste puisque la
baisse des effectifs scolaires nous
oblige à ajuster la carte scolaire et
donc nous supprimons un certain nombre
de postes en effet à la rentrée dans des
proportions relatives d'ailleurs puisque
cela ne se fait pas à proportion de la
baisse des effectifs scolaires ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que le taux
d'encadrement c'est à dire le nombre
d'élèves par classe va continuer à
baisser l'année prochaine dans le
primaire et dans le secondaire mais en
effet il y aura des suppressions de
poste quand vous estimez à combien ah
bah nous l'avons déjà annoncé puisque
c'est dans le budget 2023 environ 1500
suppressions de poste avec des
ajustements que nous faisons nous avons
rétabli 400 postes à peu près depuis le
mois février en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux là où les questions
d'éloignement sont particulièrement
importantes un dernier mot sur la
question de la mixité scolaire puisque
c'est aussi l'un de vos cheveux de
battre de dialogue autour de la carte
scolaire pour réunir le préfet les
associations d'élus pourquoi quel est le
besoin il y a un problème entre le privé
le public une tendance toujours très
prononcée à contourner la carte scolaire
dans notre pays alors ça ça peut être
vrai en effet dans les grands centres
urbains mais d'une manière générale nous
savons que la mixité sociale elle est
positive elle est positive non seulement
pour les élèves favorisés mais également
à fortiori pour les élèves défavorisés
or la France est un des pays où la
ségrégation scolaire et la plus forte et
très très pharison internationale
nous savons que la relevé le niveau
scolaire et nous avons besoin de relever
le niveau scolaire passe par un certain
nombre de mesures comme le renforcement
des mathématiques que nous allons
introduire dès la rentrée mais aussi par
le meilleur mixité scolaire et sociale
c'est donc ce que nous allons proposer
il y a plusieurs leviers pour cela la
sectorisation évidemment c'est quelque
chose de très important regardez ce qui
a été fait à Paris par exemple dans les
lycées parisiens on a une augmentation
très très intéressante de la mixité
sociale avec une refonte de la carte
scolaire il y a la question de
l'implantation de filière d'excellence
j'en parlais à l'instant de filaire
attractive dans des collèges défavorisés
pour conserver des familles je dirais de
classes moyennes qui sinon s'en irait
ailleurs et puis en effet il y a la
question de la participation de
l'enseignement privé sous contrat
puisque je dirais que le contournement
de la carte scolaire est important dans
des grandes villes dans des grandes
métropoles comme Paris et donc nous
espérons parvenir
par exemple à Paris c'est tout à fait le
cas essayez de mettre fin à ça
de telle sorte que l'enseignement privé
prenne sa part de la mixité scolaire et
sociale merci beaucoup papa merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin merci Stéphane on passe au club
des territoires à parler de la fin de
vie